en esta misma Plaza Pedro cerolo en el
madrileño barrio de Chueca iniciarán
oficialmente esta noche las fiestas del
orgullo en Madrid son las primeras que
se celebran con una ley para la igualdad
de las personas trans y para la garantía
de los Derechos lgtbi en vigor en todo
el país que entre otras cosas de
patologizaba la transexualidad al no
requerir un tratamiento de hormonación
de dos años para cambiarse de sexo en el
registro civil también es el primer
orgullo que se da en plena precampaña
electoral de los comicios del 23 de
julio y con los gobiernos locales y
regionales aún Terminando de formarse
tras las elecciones municipales del 28
de mayo las organizaciones lgtbiqmas
muestran su preocupación por lo que está
ocurriendo en varias ciudades y regiones
españolas donde el partido de
ultraderecha vox ha entrado a gobernar
en coalición y en las que ha exigido que
se elimine la bandera arcoíris de los
edificios públicos el colectivo diverso
advierte de que estos movimientos
antiderechos cada vez tienen más
presencia en Europa y esto preocupa
porque España es después de Brasil el
país del mundo con un mayor porcentaje
de población lgbti un 14% declara tener
una orientación sexual No normativa
cifra que sube al 18% en los jóvenes de
entre 18 y 24 años el broche final a
esta semana del orgullo de Madrid será
el sábado primero de julio en la marcha
Estatal que podría recibir más de un
millón de personas